la fonction de maire au pluriel c'est le
pari du village de vandoncourt près de
montbéliard chez un village avec chiche
en mer en 1971 c'est bien jean-pierre
maillard salins sans étiquette qui est
élu à la tête de la commune à ceci près
qu'il décide aussitôt de partager sa
fonction avec tous les villageois
il s'agit donc pas de diriger les gens
il s'agit de les mettre en animation et
yang et une pac le mouvement est
déclenché et j'ai ça qui est intéressant
et bien une fois que ce mouvement est en
route
on ne peut pas l'arrêter comme partout
en france vandoncourt à son conseil
municipal mais en plus trois instances
ont été mis en place le conseil des
sages composé de personnes âgées
chaque fois que je suis quelque part
avec des anciens s'armer vox a remué le
conseil des fous pour les jeunes et les
jeunes ont justement une importance dans
la commune on leur a donné des
responsabilités et le conseil des
sociétés qui représente les associations
du village toutes les compétences
classiques d'une mairie sont gérés par
ce beau monde
les déchets l'urbanisme l'animation à
vandoncourt dès les années 70 la
démocratie et direct
il apparaît difficile de dire aux gens
voilà vous votez tous les six ans vous
vous et lisez vos gens et puis après ben
pendant six ans on vous tient à l'écart
de tout ce qui se passe dans la commune
et vous n'êtes plus dans le coup mais
cette expérience survivra-t-elle à la
fin du mandat de jean pierre maillard
salins en 1978 c'est une crainte pour
une partie des habitants parce que vous
avez peur que finalement cette belle
tentative de vandoncourt s'éteignent
avec la disparition de son maire j'ai
l'impression en 1983 changement de maire
mais la démocratie participative a
perduré avant d'en cours aujourd'hui ils
sont quelques 800 habitants dans le
village toujours associé aux décisions
de la vie en communauté
[Musique]